this is our robotic garden the
inspiration behind it was that there
isn't a lot of interest especially from
young girls in computer science and not
a great way for them to get interested
and the garden is a great way to teach
some of these basic concepts in a
visually pleasing way we have over a
hundred different robotic flowers in
this garden and they can all open and
close and the LED lit flowers can also
change colors so we can show distributed
algorithms running on the garden as well
and demonstrate some basic algorithm
concepts for beginning computer
scientists you can interact with the
garden through the computer we have an
interface that shows the garden split up
into tiles and you can click on a tile
and click on a color and the flowers on
that tile will change colors or you can
make them inflate or deflate and we also
have buttons to display the distributed
algorithms that can run in the garden
one of the more interesting algorithms
that we can run on the garden is called
graph coloring and so what happens in
graph coloring is every tile will have
flowers that are a different color from
the flowers on every tile around it and
we need it most four colors to
accomplish this here
recently we displayed the garden at the
hour of code and we had some local high
school students come and try out the
garden and then when they saw the code
run in the garden kids were really
excited and one of the really neat
things that happened as a result of the
hour of code was I had a couple of kids
come up and asked me where they could
get their own components to make their
own robotic systems and how to get
started and so it really was doing what
we were hoping it would which is
inspiring kids to get interested in
robotics and programming